when they come and they will I'll come
for you I have an army we have a Hulk
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie these are
gonna be my infinity war easter eggs
hopefully you've had a chance to see the
movie but obviously spoiler warning if
you have not seen it yet because we'll
be talking about various specific things
there were also a lot of references to
earlier movies like referencing the
first Avengers film referencing Black
Panther probably one of the funniest
moments was when iron man told
spider-man to zip it no more pop-culture
references from you for the rest of this
adventure if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos this is just the
beginning we have to start talking about
Avengers 4 really soon and Captain
Marvel because they're still filming
that right now but because there's so
many of these I'm just gonna go down the
list some of these won't be in
particular order of appearance but the
very first big Easter Egg is that
distress call that they have from the as
guardianship the voice of the distress
call was Kenneth the brand now the
person who directed that first Thor
movie so lots of phase 1 Easter eggs in
the movie they also let Loki borrow that
line from Iron Man in the first Avengers
film we have a Hulk when Heimdall
transports Hulk back to the sanctum
using the power of the Bifrost he has to
use special dark energy he makes a
reference to all fathers let the dark
energy flow through me once more that's
another reference to the first Avengers
film when we see Thor show up for the
first time and meet Loki to try and
recapture him and take him back to
Asgard and Loki makes a joke about the
Bifrost being broken how much dark
energy did the all-father have to expend
to get you here so I know there are a
lot of questions about how Thor's hammer
works how it's supposed to be able to
wield the power of the Bifrost when he
enters the battle of Wakanda and the
hammer flies right out of the path of
the Bifrost is just like the way he
enters the movie during Thor the dark
world it's literally the exact same
scene so what happens now is that Asgard
has been destroyed but they can still
travel around the universe using things
like the Bifrost because the hammer can
open those wormholes so like if you
watch the first Thor movie they kind of
explained the science behind the Bifrost
it's a device that can open wormhole
but Thor says that he's the only one
that's powerful enough to wield it
The Guardian suggests hey wouldn't it be
cool if we all had hammers like that and
Thor tells them that it would basically
melt their brains as they slowly went
insane you'd have to actually have the
power of someone like Thor to be able to
wield it that's why they call it a
king's weapon
speaking of which King of the dwarves
Eitri is played by Peter Dinklage even
though it wasn't quite what I expected
from that character he's a pretty big
character in the comics as he says it's
the birthplace of his hammer Mjolnir but
also Stormbreaker is the name of beta
ray Bill's hammer in the comics so
another beta ray bill Easter Egg if you
remember he was taken out of Thor
Ragnarok he's actually on the side of
the collectors palace there's they get
ready for the games we get our Silver
Surfer reference when Hulk crash lands
into the sanctum that was the Silver
Surfer in the comic book version of
Infinity Gauntlet he's the one that
warns Doctor Strange that Thanos is
coming we learn that there are two
flavors of Ben & Jerry's
named after the Avengers and outer
strange calls out the cauldron of the
cosmos the flavors are stark raving
hazelnuts which i think is totally
appropriate but wong says that Hoka Hoka
burning fudge is actually our favorite
which is actually an Elvis reference if
you're not a big Elvis fan hunka hunka
burnin love the cauldron of the cosmos
is sort of like a TV that you can use to
witness historical events all over the
cosmos not really sure if Iron Man
watches Spongebob Squarepants but he
calls
evany moss Squidward's so he is at least
familiar with that TV show when
Spiderman joins the fight Ned creates
that distraction on the bus so that he
can escape Stan Lee's cameo is as the
bus driver what's the matter you kids
never saw a spaceship before six years
ago we had a whole bunch of them
speaking of which really big timeline
Easter Egg people have been pointing
this error out so I'll explain this in a
separate video too but Avengers infinity
war / Iron Man's comment is six years
after the Battle of New York but during
spider-man homecoming the title sequence
says that that movie takes place eight
years after the Battle of New York the
Russos were asked about this during the
premiere all the interviews that were
happening
they said that spider-man homecoming is
the one that made the error they're like
yeah that timeline is wrong Kevin Feige
said they very specifically try to avoid
putting dates specifically any
in these movies if they can to avoid
having problems like this pop up just
because there are so many people that
work on the films they're bound to be a
couple continuity errors that pop up so
confirm now this is six years after the
Battle of New York
eventually Kevin Feige did say they
would release an official timeline of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe for like
where certain events happen because like
Doctor Strange is a big question because
the Avengers tower exists but you're not
quite sure where it takes place relative
to the first Avengers film when we first
pick up with the guardians they're
flying through space listening to that
song rubber band man that's actually
from the Zune James Gunn confirm that's
yondu Zune that that song is on there
were no TV references I know people are
like agents of shield defenders where
the TV characters the closest we get to
a TV character reference is on groots
little game he's playing arcade
defenders the logo is in the same type
font is the classic defenders logo from
the comics so you could take that as a
defenders Easter Egg but the classic
defenders included Doctor Strange so
he's also a bit of a defenders Easter
Egg himself there was a joke about that
I from Guardians vol 2 rakats like I'm
gonna keep me this I he then gives it to
Thor you probably should have watched
that before you put that in but that
gives us the explainer for why there's a
lot of to AI versions of Thor in all the
marketing materials I think there are a
number of reasons why they did that but
pirate Angel Thor was one of the
funniest jokes from early in the film
it's like a pirate had a baby with an
angel pirate Angel also tracks because
he's the son of Odin and Frigga Odin has
one eye kind of like a pirate and Frigga
looks kind of like an angel when we go
to Wakanda Bucky gets his new arm they
make another white wolf reference white
wolf is a big character that they
reference at the end of Black Panther
even though he's a completely different
person in the comics it's always
possible that Bucky just becomes the
white wolf of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe I know there are lots of
theories about what if Captain America
dies during Avengers 4 who would become
the next Captain America Captain America
is obviously the Nomad character in this
film very big comic book twist for the
character after he laid down the mantle
said I'm not gonna be Captain America
anymore he basically hated the
government so he just went on the run
the other visual Easter Egg is that
because his costume is damaged so much
you can see the underlayer it's actually
the scale armor from the comics so it's
as close as we're ever gonna get to
scale armor Captain America pretty much
everybody picked up on the aliens and
the pop-culture movie references so
Spider Man says have you ever seen that
old movie aliens which is also a joke on
Captain America Civil War have you ever
seen that old movie Empire Strikes Back
so Spider Man is like the pop culture
movie buff of the current version of The
Avengers Peter quill is also a big Kevin
Bacon fan was a big pop-culture movie
buff but still from the 80s because he
hasn't seen any new movies since he left
Earth
the aliens reference is to the boss
battle where Ripley is battling the
Queen alien she vents it into outer
space so that's what they do to ebony
maw then they have this Kevin Bacon
Runner joke with the guardians where
they're like Earth's Mightiest Heroes
when Thor's tried to explain The
Avengers and mantas is like are you
talking about Kevin Bacon like she
thinks the Kevin Bacon is one of Earth's
Mightiest Heroes because he's a big 80s
movie star when they're on Titan
spider-man references Footloose another
Kevin Bacon movie in star-lord says is
it still the best movie of all time and
then spider-man starts the argument like
almost argument where he's like it never
was the greatest movie of all time
star-lord is physically wounded at the
thought that spider-man thinks that
Footloose isn't the greatest movie of
all time until Ironman cuts them off
short alright no more when they're
arguing about what the plan should be to
fight Thanos to make a joke about the
dance-off from the end of the first
guardians film tell him about the
dance-off to save the galaxy
during the fan of battle on Titan they
have a full-blown wizard battle within
that battle Doctor Strange uses the
crimson bands of cyttorak those are like
the extra red ones when he makes this
pose and splits himself into a bunch of
different versions and he has those
spaghetti strands that try to hold
Thanos those are just regular bonds but
this is actually a comic book panel
right here when he's making this pose
the bigger thicker bands when they're
actually trying to pull the gauntlet off
of his hand those are the crimson bands
of cyttorak
there are all kinds of Doctor Strange
portal jokes where they're all jumping
around through portals trying to get
Thanos before he can get their hands on
him spider-man webs him up in the face
that's right out of the comic book when
Thanos is fighting people during
different parts of the movie like when
he turns mantis into that ribbon version
of herself and he turns Drax into the
blocks though
our panels right out of the comic book
probably the most iconic comic book
reference was the finger snap itself
they even refer to it three different
times with a bunch of different
characters just foreshadowing that that
would be happening during the movie
there weren't that many iron spider
references but when his legs come out he
says what are those that's actually a
Black Panther reference to when Sheree
is making fun of Black Panther sandals
they make a joke about spider-man being
Iron Man's Ward that's just a Batman
Robin reference he's like no no no we're
not that's not our relationship they do
make a reference to Iron Man's potential
son with Pepper Potts that's Morgan
start which is an idea from the comics
they did tone down some of the violence
at the beginning of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book storyline Thanos is
tormenting nebula which leads to a big
twist at the end of Infinity Gauntlet
where she gets to wield it and try to
turn the tables on Thanos turnabout is
fair play but when he shows Gamora what
he's been doing to nebula that's what
this is referring to they got really
meta with some of the references to so
like there were a bunch of jokes when
they first showed pictures off of Thanos
in the first trailer like there was the
king of the hill there was the simpsons
reference everybody was just making fun
of Thanos his appearance so star-lord
has this line of dialogue where he calls
him chrimbus then talks about his
nutsack of a chin so that's basically
just giving a voice to all the people
making fun of what Thanos looks like
probably one of the biggest Easter eggs
is when they go to voir Mir and we see
the red skull like I said this is Ross
mark and not Hugo Weaving so Easter Egg
within an Easter Egg Walking Dead
character playing a version of red skull
would just sort of become an homage to
the aspect of death in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but he did say that
he's been prisoner to the soul gem meant
to guide wayward adventurers but never
allowed to possess the soul gem himself
because he said that he tried to possess
one of them it banished me here and he's
been trapped there so it's implied that
red skull has been on this planet ever
since then but remember that he has the
Super Soldier Serum so he was probably
alive for a portion of that he also
references Thanos his father a large
from Titan if you don't know him as that
you might know him as mentor his real
name is a large but he's one of the
Eternals there were a portion of the
Eternals that went to live on titan the
Eternals is a
movie that they might be making it phase
four maybe we'll see some of those
characters pop up during that the black
order characters are a big reference to
Marvel's infinity storyline which
happened just a couple years ago
Infinity Gauntlet is a comic from the
early 90s but the infinity Marvel's
infinity is from just a couple years ago
the black order are basically like his
dark version of The Avengers they were
kind of underpowered during the movie
but Proxima midnight Corvus glaive
Eponine ma in black dwarf of the only
characters they left out supergiant
because she kind of looks like nebula
I'm assuming and they just didn't want
to put too many characters in but the
dogs with the forearms that they
attacked them with the big army were
meant to be the outriders which are also
creatures that Thanos uses to send out
into the universe I think we're all
probably in agreement that at certain
points in the film Thanos goes into what
you could consider the sole world of the
soul gem more recently in the comics the
colors of the infinity gems and sort of
the color scheme has been changed to
look more like what it is in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe comic book soul gem
is now orange like it is in the movies
but the soul world also looks very
orange like the world that the a knows
goes to when he snaps his fingers so
it's not a hundred percent confirmation
but I do think that that's what they're
going for when he's talking to little
Gamora here after he's erased half of
all life Gamora like I said in my last
big soul gem video so that she was
coming back to film scenes for Avengers
4 and obviously all the people that were
turned to ash will eventually come back
because Black Panther spider-man they're
both getting sequel movies even though
they were turned to ash so with a very
end of the film when Thanos sits down on
what looks like gamora's planet that he
said it had become a paradise since he
erased half of all life to just rest
he's like I would rest and enjoy a
grateful galaxy this is a panel right
out of the Infinity Gauntlet comic book
the really big Captain Marvel Easter Egg
during that post-credit scene is when
her symbol shows up on that modified 90s
pager the Captain Marvel movie is set
during the 90s so I think the fact that
they used a pager that was souped up to
call her on it's just a reference to
that time period there been a couple
pictures from the set - I was a little
disappointed because they're going with
a die-hard Nick Fury from die hard 3
just look the same haircut instead of
doing Pulp Fiction Nick Fury with the
sideburns in the fro but oh well
if you're a really big Russo brothers
fan you may have noticed the Arrested
Development Easter egg so Tobias when he
blew himself Blue Man Group joke is
actually inside one of the collectors
pods when they go to get fan oohs when
he's trying to take the reality gem so I
don't know who that actor is but that is
Tobias blue but let me know in the
comments if you spotted any other
pop-culture references or Easter eggs
that I didn't mention in the video this
video is already getting super long so
there are probably a billion other
things that they embedded in the film
and this is just Avengers 3 remember we
have Avengers for next year it's gonna
be even crazier what'll happen is is
I'll be doing more infinity war and
Avengers for Captain Marvel videos
through the next couple of weeks leave
all your requests in the comments below
so there will be new Marvel tomorrow but
there's a new round of the Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway going on all you have
to do to enter that is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video click
here for my soul gem video and click
here for my full review of the movie
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]